well I'm afraid it's not looking good in
fact it is below what was expected
forecasters expected that there would be
a 0.3 rise in retail sales volumes it's
actually down by 0.3 so clearly not good
news and this off the back of a rise in
retail sales volumes in October that was
described at the time as a bounce back a
flash dawn after the bank holiday for
the Queen's funeral in September at
sales though are still well below
pre-pandemic levels across all months
even though there was like rise in
October and well below what they would
normally be at this time of year for
November as well so what it shows is
inflation is still really squeezing
households hard off the back of the bank
of England's decision to raise interest
rates by five basis points yesterday I
guess that could have been worse it
would have been higher but still really
difficult for people with mortgages
um let's look a little bit further into
the detail of those figures out today
from retail sales and they do include
Black Friday but they don't include
Cyber Monday so that could skew it a
little bit although it's a full still
online sales we're down by 2.8 non-food
purchase is also down and at the only
um area to rise was food that was up by
0.9 but the thinking is is that people
are really trying to stock up
um on food ahead of Christmas and so
there's no winter cheer here at the
retailers that we've spoken to in the
last couple of days have actually said
that the strikes politics aside are not
helping them because of course it
decreases at footfall here in the shops
and the strikes with Royal Mail as well
deliveries too so people are want any
travel disruptions going to affect those
sorts of things and of course this is
the busiest time it's supposed to be the
busiest time of year for retailers on
the ground consumer confidence the
consumer confidence index is out today
as well that's up two points up a little
bit I suppose but it's still at historic
lows so that's not good in the days
before Christmas and it's in likely that
we'll see a rebound in confidence
anytime soon